it was all over the Internet like
everyone said Saturday Night Live has to
have John Levitz back to do his liar and
be George Santos and it seemed like a
very brilliant idea right I mean it's
your calling there should be a film The
George Santos movie and everything right
I mean this is your mom would be funny I
would say it's his spokesman for George
Santos then he lies anymore why did he
say this why you know like the press
secretary what happened John was it like
as soon as this guy Santos came on the
scene and they realized what a liar he
was did everyone just sort of start
calling you immediately and saying
you've got to be George Santos yeah I
mean it's funny it's like it's a good
thing from for me in my career your
character on Saturday Night Live was
Tommy Flanagan you developed that
character with the Groundlings I didn't
realize this whole history of it the
Groundlings they have their Sunday
company you do their school then they
have their like the B company the Sunday
company so that's the first time I did
it and I had the first two lines and
it's called panel and there's a post and
they go there's going to be like six of
you and come up with your a character
and your name and what you do so they go
okay and who are you I go oh my name is
Tommy Flanagan I'm a member of
pathological Liars Anonymous in fact I I
am the President of that organization
and I was playing it like an old movie
character from the 30s because I like
those old movies and then they asked me
the audience to ask questions they go
how long have you been lying I go I
never lied and the truth is uh I Gotta
Give Robin Schiff who um
she wrote Romy and Michelle you know big
writer she was in the group and she goes
John just stay in character and you can
say anything you set it up perfectly
I didn't even realize it and she goes
I'll ask you a question what's your
favorite sport and I went uh bowling and
we started laughing and I go oh my God
everything and I go I did it finally and
then I got in the main company the
growlings and I wrote a monologue of a
guy like at an AAA meeting but instead
of a a it was like pathological Liars
Anonymous you know they get up and they
say hi I'm Bob I'm an alcoholic here's
my story so I thought wouldn't it be
funny if a guy got up and said he was a
pathological liar and then told a story
and then started lying about it that's
right and that's how it started
foreign